CHRIS.
>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARK, THANKS.
JOINING US NOW LIVE FROM HIS
OFFICE IN THE WEST WING,
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, WELCOME BACK
TO "FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Vice President Pence: GOOD
MORNING, CHRIS.
>> Chris: I WANT TO START WITH
THOSE GROWING PROTESTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AGAINST THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
SOME OF THE PROTESTERS IGNORING
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SPECIFICALLY
OF THEIR PROTESTS AND HOW THEY
ARE CARRYING THEM OUT?
>> Vice President Pence:
FIRST, LET ME SAY, FROM THE
MOMENT PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED ME
TO LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE TWO
MONTHS AGO, HE MADE IT CLEAR
THAT WE HAVE ONE OBJECTIVE, AND
THAT WAS TO SAVE LIVES.
AND IN THE INTERVENING TWO
MONTHS, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
STEPPED FORWARD, HAVE EMBRACED
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING, HAVE DONE
THE MITIGATION EFFORTS AND AS WE
SIT HERE THIS MORNING, WE
CONTINUE TO SEE ENCOURAGING
RESULTS, DECLINING CASES,
DECLINING HOSPITALIZATIONS.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE DONE, BECAUSE OF THE
PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP AND WHAT
GOVERNORS HAVE DONE AROUND THE
COUNTRY, WE ARE SLOWING THE
SPREAD.
WE ARE HASTENING THE DAY WHEN WE
CAN PUT THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE
PAST AND REOPEN THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
THE ON THE FOCUS ON LIVES, THE
PRESIDENT ALSO MADE IT CLEAR
THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
HOSPITAL WORKERS, INCREDIBLE MEN
AND WOMEN, HAD THE RESOURCES AND
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NEEDED.
WE SPENT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO THE CRITICAL
AREAS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND I MUST TELL YOU, THE FACT
THAT NO AMERICAN WHO HAS NEEDED
A VENTILATOR HAS BEEN DENIED IN
VENTILATOR, IT’S A GREAT
TESTAMENT TO OUR NATIONAL
RESPONSE AT EVERY LEVEL.
AND ON THE SUBJECT OF TESTING,
WE ARE CONTINUING TO SCALE AND
EXPAND TESTING AND WE WILL DO
THAT BECAUSE AS THE PRESIDENT
LAID OUT THOSE GUIDELINES THIS
WEEK, NO ONE WANTS TO REOPEN
AMERICA MORE THAN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
AND WHAT YOU SEE I THINK AMONG
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO HAVE
BEEN EMBRACING THOSE SOCIAL
DISTANCING MEASURES AND MAKING
THE SACRIFICES IS THEY WANT
THEIR GOVERNORS TO FIND A WAY TO
RESPONSIBLY AND SAFELY REOPEN
THEIR STATE ECONOMIES AND WHAT
THE PRESIDENT LAID OUT LAST WEEK
IS A FRAMEWORK, A PHASED
FRAMEWORK TO REOPEN AMERICA, TO
DO THAT, AND WE’RE GOING TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH GOVERNORS TO
IMPLEMENT THAT AS SOON AS WE CAN
RESPOND --
>> Chris:
MR. VICE PRESIDENT --
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, AND A NUMBER
OF THESE CASES, THESE
PROTESTERS, WHO ARE NOT SOCIAL
DISTANCING ARE SAYING THEY DON’T
WANT TO WAIT.
IN MANY CASES THEY ARE
PROTESTING YOUR OWN GUIDELINES
TO STOP THE SPREAD.
ON FRIDAY THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
THIS, AND I WANT TO PUT IT UP.
IF LIBERATE MINNESOTA.
IT LIBERATE MICHIGAN.
AND LIBERATE VIRGINIA AND SAVE
YOUR GREAT SECOND AMENDMENT.
IT IS UNDER SIEGE.
WASHINGTON GOVERNOR INSLEE
RESPONDED, THE PRESIDENT IS
FOMENTING DOMESTIC REBELLION AND
SPREADING LIES EVEN WHILE HIS
OWN ADMINISTRATION SAYS THE
VIRUS IS REAL AND DEADLY.
SO WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT MEAN,
BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT GUIDELINES
THAT ARE CALLING FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND STAYING AT HOME.
EVEN YOUR NEW GUIDELINES TO
REOPEN THE COUNTRY ARE VERY
PHASED AND GRADUAL.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT MEAN WHEN
HE SAYS LIBERATE THESE STATES?
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
NO ONE IN AMERICA WANTS TO
REOPEN THIS COUNTRY MORE THAN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
AND ON THURSDAY, THE PRESIDENT
DIRECTED US TO LAY OUT
GUIDELINES FOR WHEN AND HOW
STATES COULD RESPONSIBLY DO THAT
AND IN THE PRESIDENT’S TWEETS
AND PUBLIC STATEMENTS, I CAN
ASSURE YOU HE’S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE GOVERNORS
TO FIND WAYS TO SAFELY AND
RESPONSIBLY LET AMERICA GO BACK
TO WORK.
AND THE GUIDELINES FOR OPENING
UP AMERICA AGAIN GIVE A ROAD MAP
FOR DOING JUST THAT, CHRIS.
14 DAYS OF CONSECUTIVE DECLINING
CASES THAT HAVE A PROPER
HOSPITALIZATION CAPACITY, WE
RECOMMEND THAT THEY CAN BEGIN,
UNDER PHASE ONE, TO EASE THE
SOCIAL -- SOCIAL DISTANCING
MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
EFFECT, ALLOW SOME PEOPLE TO
BEGIN TO COME BACK TO WORK.
ALLOW SOME ACTIVITIES IN THE
COMMUNITY TO HAPPEN AND WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SPEAKS ABOUT REOPENING
AMERICA, IT’S ALL ABOUT THE
COURAGE AND GOVERNORS AS SOON AS
THEY DETERMINE HIS MOST PROPER
AND MOST APPROPRIATE TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT AND DO THAT QUICKLY.
AMERICA WORKS AT --
>> Chris:
MR. VICE PRESIDENT --
>> Vice President Pence: THE
PRESIDENT WANTS US TO SEE BUT
THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE PAST.
BY THE STRONG MEASURES THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE EMBRACED
BUT WE WANT TO GET AMERICA
WORKING AGAIN JUST AS SOON AS WE
CAN.
>> Chris: UNDERSTOOD,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT YOUR
PLANS TO REOPEN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
HEALTH EXPERTS THAT SAY WE NEED
TRIPLE THE NUMBER OF TESTS THAT
ARE NOW BEING CONDUCTED AND MUCH
MORE CONTACT TRACING IN ORDER TO
SAFELY REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
CAN YOU TELL US THAT -- HOW SOON
THAT YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
500,000 TESTS A DAY, WHICH IS
WHAT THEY’RE CALLING FOR, WE ARE
DOING ABOUT 150,000 NOW.
HOW SOON ARE WE GOING TO HAVE
500,000 TESTS A DAY OR DON’T YOU
THINK THAT’S NECESSARY?
>> Vice President Pence: WELL,
UNDER THE GUIDELINES FOR OPENING
UP AMERICA, AGAIN, WE CREATE, IN
PHASE ONE, A SPECIFIC CRITERIA
FOR TESTING THAT WE BELIEVE IS
APPROPRIATE TO BE ABLE TO TEST
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SYMPTOMS FOR
CORONAVIRUS AND BE ABLE TO
MONITOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
SERIOUS OUTCOMES, NURSING HOMES
AND PARTICULAR POPULATIONS IN
OUR CITIES THAT HAVE SHOWN SOME
VULNERABILITY.
THAT’S -- WE BELIEVE THE TESTING
THAT WE HAVE TODAY, CHRIS,
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ONCE WE
ACTIVATE ALL OF THE LABS THAT
CAN DO CORONAVIRUS TESTING IS
SUFFICIENT FOR ANY STATE IN
AMERICA TO MOVE INTO PHASE ONE.
WE ARE DOING ABOUT 150,000 TESTS
A DAY AND, REMEMBER, A MONTH AGO
WE HAD DONE 80,000 TESTS TOTAL.
NOW WE’VE CLEARED 4 MILLION
OVERALL.
BUT IN 150,000 TESTS A DAY WITH
THINK CAN DOUBLE THAT NUMBER BUT
WORKING WITH GOVERNORS TO
ACTIVATE ALL OF THE LABORATORIES
IN THEIR STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY THAT CAN DO CORONAVIRUS
TESTING.
THAT WOULD PUT US AT ROUGHLY
300,000, BUT WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO MAKE CLEAR TO GOVERNORS AGAIN
TOMORROW IN OUR WEEKLY
CONFERENCE CALL AND I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
DIRECTION, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FULLY PARTNER WITH
GOVERNORS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
HEALTH OFFICIALS IN INCREASING
AND SCALING THE AMOUNT OF
TESTING, AND WE HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT WE CAN HAVE A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF TESTING TO
BE ABLE TO REOPEN AMERICA, NOT
JUST IN PHASE ONE, BUT CONTINUE
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD TO
EXPAND TESTING IN WAYS THAT WILL
GIVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
CONFIDENCE AND THE TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK.
>> Chris: MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
I FELT LIMITED TIME WITH YOU SO
I’M GOING TO TRY TO SQUEEZE A
FEW MORE QUESTIONS THEN.
THE $350 BILLION PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE LOANS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES HAS RUN OUT AND YOU
STILL DON’T HAVE A DEAL ON
REPLENISHING THAT WITH ANOTHER
$250 BILLION.
HOW CLOSE ARE YOU TO A DEAL WITH
THE DEMOCRATS?
>> Vice President Pence: THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM THAT
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED INTO LAW
HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE SUCCESS.
AND LITERALLY HAS MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AROUND AMERICA TO KEEP PEOPLE ON
THE PAYROLL OVER A TWO-MONTH
PERIOD OF TIME WHILE WE WEATHER
THE STORM WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
BUT AS THE PRESIDENT AND I WERE
LITERALLY ON THE PHONE CALL WITH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS LAST
WEEK, WE LEARNED THAT THE FUND
HAD RUN OUT AND WE ARE URGING
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE TO STEP FORWARD AND
APPROVE AN EXPANSION OF THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION BILL.
WE ARE CLOSE --
>> Chris: HOW CLOSE ARE YOU TO
IT, SIR?
>> Vice President Pence: THE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING ON.
WE ARE VERY CLOSE, BUT I THINK
EVERY AMERICAN HAS SEEN THE
SUCCESS OF THE PRESIDENT’S
PROGRAM PROVIDE PAYROLL SUPPORT
AND WE ARE GOING TO WORK TO
EXPAND THAT SO THAT NO ONE
WORKING IN A SMALL BUSINESS IN
AMERICA WOULD HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT MISSING A PAYCHECK DURING
THE TRIAL AND DIFFICULTY OF THE
CORONAVIRUS EPIDEMIC.
>> Chris: SEVERAL SOURCES NOW
SAY THAT THE CORONAVIRUS
ORIGINATED IN A LAB IN WUHAN AND
THAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
COVERED IT UP FOR SOME PERIOD OF
TIME WHICH ALLOW THE VIRUS TO
SPREAD.
SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS WHILE THE
PRESIDENT IMPOSED HIS TRAVEL BAN
IN JANUARY, HE MINIMIZED THE
THREAT FROM A VIRUS.
HERE SHE IS, SIR.
>> CALLING IT A HOAX INSTEAD OF
CALLING IT -- MINIMIZING AND
SAYING WE MAGICALLY DISAPPEARED.
WE LOST TIME.
THE DELAYING AND THE DENIAL, AND
THAT’S JUST THE WAY IT IS.
>> Chris: MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
I’M GETTING THIS QUESTION A LOT
AND AGAIN, I’VE GOT TO ASK YOU
FOR A BRIEF ANSWER, WHAT
SPECIFICALLY IS THIS
ADMINISTRATION GOING TO DO TO
HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE?
>> Vice President Pence: WELL,
I APPRECIATE YOU REFERENCING THE
FACT THAT BY THE END OF JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK THE UNPRECEDENTED STEP OF
SUSPENDING ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA.
NO AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAD EVER
DONE THAT AND THERE’S NO
QUESTION ALL OF OUR HEALTH
EXPERTS AGREE THAT THAT BOUGHT
US AN INVALUABLE AMOUNT OF TIME,
IT’S ENABLED US TO SAVE LIVES
AND MAKE SURE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED TO MEET THIS MOMENT.
BUT IT IS CLEAR TO US THAT NOT
ONLY WAS THERE A FAILURE BY THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO
COMMUNICATE TO AMERICA AND THE
WORLD WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
CHINA, BUT ALSO THAT CHINA WAS
NOT AS FORTHCOMING AS THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN WITH AMERICA OR
THE WORLD ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE IT
CLEAR HE’S NOT HAPPY.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE PROPER
INQUIRIES INTO THIS AT THE
PROPER TIME, BUT I HAVE TO TELL
YOU, THE ONE MISSION THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE IS TO SAVE LIVES, TO
PUT THIS CORONAVIRUS IN THE
PAST.
WE ARE GOING TO STAY FOCUSED ON
THAT MISSION.
IT’S ONE MISSION AND ONE TEAM.
WE’RE GOING TO WORK WITH
GOVERNORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
BOTH POLITICAL PARTIES AND I
JUST WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
BE ENCOURAGED BY THE FACT THAT
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS, WE
REALLY DO SEE DOWNWARD TRENDS IN
CASES AND IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE DONE, BECAUSE OF OUR
INCREDIBLE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
THAT WE ARE TOGETHER AS A NATION
HASTENING THE DAY ONE WE WILL
PUT THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE PAST
AND GET AMERICA WORKING AGAIN.
>> Chris:
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME DURING A